[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les matins du
sénat rendre compatibles les avancées
médicales avec ce que la société
française considère comme acceptable tel
est l'objectif du projet loi bioéthique
déposé au parlement par le gouvernement
le texte est actuellement au sénat une
commission spéciale a été mise en place
pour l'étudier hier les ministres
étaient auditionnés ils ont notamment
été interrogés sur l'une des promesses
phares du candidat macron la pma pour
toute la procréation médicalement
assistée pour les couples de femmes et
les femmes célibataires cette réforme
doit être la première réforme sociétale
du quinquennat on regarde l'audition on
se retrouve juste après sur public sénat
effectivement je devrais vous quittez à
16h30 puisque je vais je serai dans
l'hémicycle là pardon à 17h30
pardonnez-moi à 17h30 je serai dans
l'hémicycle pour la ppl dit pradier
voilà donc effectivement comme vous le
disiez dans la mesure où le texte
le projet de loi ouvre la pma avec tiers
donneur aux couples de femmes
il fallait nécessairement tirer les
conséquences de cette ouverture en
termes de filiation et c'est l'article 4
que vous évoquiez et sur lequel
j'interviens particulièrement cette
question de l'établissement de la
filiation elle a suscité beaucoup
d'interrogations qui sont tout à fait
légitimes et comme vous le savez puisque
plusieurs hypothèses avaient été
soumises au conseil d'état plusieurs
options étaient envisageables
parmi ces options je les rappelle
brièvement il y avait soit l'extension
du droit commun si je peux utiliser ce
terme encore qu'il soit assez impropre
il y avait également la possibilité de
créer un dispositif haddock qui soit
applicable à l'ensemble des couples
hétérosexuels comme homosexuels qui ont
recours à une pma avec tiers donneur
ou bien troisième hypothèse la création
d'un dispositif haddock qui soit
applicable lui seulement aux couples de
femmes ayant recours à la pma avec tiers
donneur
vraiment il y à des débats extrêmement
intense entre les tenants de telle ou
telle solution et il y a dans mon propos
vraiment aucun aucune critique à l'égard
des tenants de telle ou telle solution
puisque chacune de ces solutions a ses
avantages et ses inconvénients
ces avantages et inconvénients
d'ailleurs été relevés dans les
différents avis et rapports qui ont été
rendues dans le cadre de la préparation
de la loi bioéthique et ils vous ont
sans doute été largement exposées au
cours des auditions que vous avez pu
avoir chacun de ses rapports ou à vis à
privilégier une option différente et
d'ailleurs il faut noter qu'aucun des
pays voisins qui ont ouvert la pma avec
tiers donneur à des couples de femmes
n'a retenu la même solution en termes de
filiation ça confirme donc tout à fait
que c'est une question qui est très
complexe et qu'on peut en avoir des
approches différentes ce qui s'est
imposé au gouvernement
en revanche dans la recherche du
meilleur moyen d'établir cette filiation
ce sont des principes et des objectifs
sur lesquels nous avons voulu construire
ce dispositif d'établissement de la
filiation
ces principes simples sont au nombre de
quatre et 106 au nombre de quatre
d'abord nous avons voulu offrir aux
enfants
neda mp au sein d'un couple de femmes
absolument et en tous points les mêmes
droits que aux autres enfants
c'est un choix d'égalité entre les
enfants quel que soit leur mode
d'établissement de la filiation qui est
ici affirmé de manière très claire et
qui est affirmé dans un article qui est
placé au fronton du code civil
deuxième principe nous avons souhaité
apporter de la sécurité juridique aux
deux maires
et à leurs enfants l'affiliation en
effet dans cette hypothèse est d'une
certaine manière c'est pour moi une
évolution extrêmement forte
la filiation n'est pas établie sur le
principe de la vraisemblance biologique
par définition elle ne peut pas l'être
et donc elle est établie sur la base
d'un engagement commun
c'est une évolution forte juste mais qui
doit être évidemment juridiquement
solidement établie troisième principe
nous avons souhaité établir une
procédure simple simple qui n'impose pas
de démarche supplémentaire pour les
couples de femmes qui veulent y avoir
recours pour évidemment pouvoir établir
leur filiation avec leurs enfants
quatrième principe également très
prégnant
nous n'avons pas voulu revenir sur le
droit qui était applicable aux couples
hétérosexuels
nous avons fait en sorte que au fond ce
texte apporte des droits nouveaux aux
conséquences de l'ouverture d'un droit
nouveau pour les couples de femmes
mais nous n'avons rien voulu retirée ou
modifiée du régime de la filiation tel
qu'il est applicable aux couples
hétérosexuels c'était un point très
important pour nous sur la base de ces
quatre principes tels que chien de les
énoncer nous avons fait le choix d'un
dispositif ad-hoc pour l'établissement
de la filiation pour les couples de
femmes ayant recours à la mp avec tiers
donneur
le dispositif tel qu'il a été proposé
par le gouvernement dans le projet de
loi initial a fait l'objet de débats
très important à l'assemblée notamment
en commissions dans l'hémicycle au 6 mai
en commission et il se présente très
brièvement de la manière suivante il a
été enrichi par ces débats et il se
présente de la manière suivante il ya
trois points qui me semble important
tout d'abord les femmes vous le savez
donc veulent recourir à la haine qui
attire d'honneur les femmes doivent
consentir devant notaire à faire une pma
avec tiers donneur c'est d'ailleurs le
cas également aujourd'hui pour les
couples hétérosexuels
au même moment devant ce notaire elles
s'engageront lors de ce même entretien à
devenir les mère de l'enfant à naître
donc il y à la fois le consentement à la
mp et le fait que au même moment elles
vont s'engager à devenir les mère de
l'enfant à naître
cette reconnaissance conjointe cet
engagement c'est une reconnaissance
conjointe et c'est la deuxième élément
cette reconnaissance conjointe sera
produite au moment de la naissance
devant l'officier d'état civil en même
temps que le certificat d'accouchement
ce qui permettra en même temps au même
moment d'établir la filiation à l'égard
des deux mers troisième point la ctt
intégrale de naissance de l'enfant qu'on
portera la mention que l'enfant a été
reconnue conjointement par ces deux mers
ce dispositif a évolué vous le savez
évidemment puisque vous avez vu la
manière dont les débats ont été conduits
ce dispositif a évolué dans le cadre
d'un travail qui a été mené avec les
rapporteurs à l'assemblée nationale et
ces modifications qui ont été conduites
avec un rapporteur à l'assemblée
nationale ne remettent pas en cause les
objectifs rappelé plus haut
ces modifications elles ont porté
essentiellement sur deux points que par
rapport au projet initial du
gouvernement
les modifications ont porté sur deux
points que je rappelle brièvement ici le
premier point c'est la place de ces
dispositions dans le code civil
le projet initial créée dans le code
civil
un nouveau titre 7 bis qui était propre
à la filiation des enfants nés de
couples de femmes ayant recours à la mp
le dispositif qui a été adopté
à l'issue du vote à l'assemblée
nationale lui il est intégré dans le
titre 7 dans le titre 7 du code civil
dont il n'y a pas de titre cette baisse
il est intégré dans le titre 7 du code
civil du livre premier qui est relatives
à la filiation au sein de ce titre 7 ont
créé un nouveau chapitre 5 qui porte sur
le recours à la mp avec tiers donneur
pour tous les couples pour tous les
couples et au sein de ce chapitre qui
est parfaitement organisé on va
distinguer d'abord les dispositions
communes qui s'applique à tous les
couples couples hétérosexuels ou couples
homosexuels qui ont recours à la mp avec
tiers donneur on y trouvera des
principes généraux comme l'interdiction
d'établir un lien de finesse de
filiation avec le donneur les conditions
et formes du consentement etc puis
ensuite nous trouvons les dispositions
qui permettent d'établir la filiation
pour les couples de femmes
donc un chapitre organiser les
dispositions communes et les
dispositions applicables aux couples de
femmes
cette modification de l'emplacement des
dispositions non je parle dans le code
civil pour nous avait pour objet de
rendre compte du socle commun entre ces
modes de filiation il permet donc de
rapprocher autant qu'il est possible
les modes de filiation des mots des
talismans de la filiation des couples de
femmes et des couples hétérosexuels qui
ont recours à la mp avec tiers donneur
pour autant ce déplacement ne bouleverse
pas le droit de la filiation dès lors
que les quatre premiers chapitres du
titre 7 consacrée à la filiation qui
repose sur la vraisemblance biologique
ne sont pas modifiés les couples
hétérosexuels qui ont recours à un tiers
donneur je le répète ne voit pas le
modifier le mode d'établissement de leur
filiation
donc ça c'était la première modification
telle qu'elle est résulté des débats à
l'assemblée nationale il ya une seconde
modification et elle concerne la notion
de reconnaissance conjointe
le projet de loi initial avait créé ce
qu'on avait appelé une déclaration
anticipée de volonté une d'avs
l'article 4 tel qu'il a été réécrit
substitue à cette déclaration anticipée
de volonté une
reconnaissance conjointe cette notion de
reconnaissance conjointe c'est une
réponse à la critique qui avait été
formulée à à propos de l'adav la
déclaration type et de volonté l'adav
qui apparaissait comme un concept et un
objet juridique nouveau qui aux yeux de
certains pouvaient apparaître
stigmatisant pour certains couples de
femmes
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle et
ça cela son importance le gouvernement a
décidé d'assumer la volonté de réduire
au maximum la différence entre les
couples hétérosexuels et les couples de
femmes tout en assurant l'exigence
évidemment de sécurité juridique il n'y
a en effet pas de confusion possible
entre la reconnaissance conjointe tel
que nous l'avons établi pour la mp avec
tiers donneur pour les couples de femmes
et la reconnaissance de l'article 316 du
code civil
la première la reconnaissance conjointe
elle est effectuée comme son nom
l'indiqué conjointement avant même la
grossesse tandis que la seconde celle de
l'article 316 d'une reconnaissance
unilatérale effectuer la plupart du
temps après la naissance ou au plus tôt
au début de la grossesse donc on voit
bien que ce sont deux mécanismes
différents et deux temporalités et deux
finalités différentes
la reconnaissance conjointe n'est
possible que pour les couples de femmes
tandis que la reconnaissance de
l'article 316 n'est pas ouverte aux
couples de même sexe
pour établir une double filiation
maternelle je reviens donc là
exclusivement aux couples de femmes pour
établir une double filiation maternelle
l'officier d'état civil il va avoir
besoin de deux éléments
d'abord cette reconnaissance conjointe
établi conjointement par les deux maires
et bien sûr le certificat d'accouchement
sur lequel il ne pourra pas établir
évidemment la double filiation
donc il n'ya pas de confusion possible
entre ces deux modes d'établissement de
la filiation
concrètement je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
de manière très concrète
l'acte de naissance portera la mention
de ce que l'enfant a été reconnue
conjointement par les deux maires devant
le notaire etc
cette mention donc attestera de ce qu'on
est bien dans l'hypothèse légal d'une
double filiation maternelle ainsi
modifier le dispositif qui vous est
soumis je crois constitue une voie d'
équilibre nous avons beaucoup entendu
nous avons évidemment pourquoi pas
intégrer les différentes propositions
qui nous étaient faites
nous avons cherché je leur dis devant
vous à établir quelque chose qui soit
juridiquement sûr mais qui également
soit très porteur d'égalité pour les
deux maires donc c'est une voie d'
équilibre qui répond à la nécessité de
comptes de tirer les conséquences
indispensable mais strictement
nécessaire de l'ouverture de la mp aux
couples de femmes
grâce à son double caractère à la fois
simultanée et anticiper la
reconnaissance conjointe permet de
sécuriser la filiation particulièrement
à l'égard de la femme qui n'accouche pas
les deux femmes je leur ai dis devant
vous seront en effet mr exactement en
même temps à égalité
dès lors que l'accouchement aura eu lieu
et cette reconnaissance conjointe permet
de faire obstacle à l'éventuelle
reconnaissance d'un tiers avant la
naissance puisque évidemment la
reconnaissance conjoint puis sera en
tout état de cause antérieur
et donc elle primera devant l'officier
d'état civil
c'est donc un dispositif simple
particulièrement sécurisant pour les
enfants comme pour les mères que nous
avons construit c'était la première de
nos exigences et je suis maintenant prêt
temps vous ayant redit à la fois le
contenu du dispositif mais aussi la
manière dont il a été construit je suis
évidemment prêt à répondre à vos
questions
merci madame ministre je vais de suite
passé la parole à madame jourdain et
ensuite je passerai ce qu'il désire
merci monsieur le président j'ai
plusieurs questions un vrai d'image il
est comme je sais que même le ministre
partir assez vite
effectivement ma question s'adresse à
madame le garde des sceaux monsieur le
député touraine qui est rapporteur à
l'assemblée nationale a utilisé
l'expression s'agissant de ce texte de
légitimer la procréation sans sexe pour
tous
est ce votre philosophie également sur
ce projet de loi tu peux tu peux poser
l'ensemble de gaza je peux poser
l'ensemble des questions enfin peut-être
pas trop ma deuxième question
l'extension de la mp ou aux femmes
seules et aux couples de femmes a pour
conséquence de priver les enfants de
filiation paternelle
comment peut-on expliquer cet élément au
93 % de sondés qui en 2018 estimait que
je cite les pères ont un rôle essentiel
pour les enfants ça c'est ma deuxième
question s'agissant de la fixation de la
filiation
alors est elle exclusivement fixé pour
les couples de femmes par la
reconnaissance conjointe la
reconnaissance conjointe et la règle qui
consiste à affirmer que la mer est la
femme qui accouche était inapplicable en
l'occurrence ou est-elle encore
appliquée car le texte fait référence
exclusivement à la reconnaissance
conjointe
il ya une difficulté d'ailleurs pour que
cette règle la mer est la femme qui
accouche où est inscrite dans le code
civil ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement
j'aimerais également vous puissiez nous
rappeler la raison pour laquelle la
notion de femmes non mariées ce qui est
mal apprécié je crois de beaucoup de
gens qui vit ce texte la notion de
femmes non mariées est utilisé dans le
projet de loi et enfin c'est ma dernière
question monsieur le président je
m'interrogeais sur le fait que utiliser
le terme de reconnaissance qui est une
notion qui est déjà identifiée en
réalité dans le code civil sur le droit
de la filiation et vous l'avez rappelé
alors même qu'on n'utilise pas du tout
le même régime
ce que vous avez également rappelé
n'état pas plus source de confusion que
de clarté oui le fait d'utiliser le
terme de reconnaissance
est ce que le fait de l'utiliser mais
d'appliquer un régime tout à fait
différent de celui qui existe
actuellement ce que vous avez également
indiqué à nous sommes d'accord sur ce
sur ces prémisses je dirais est-ce que
ça n'est pas plus source de confusion
que de clarté merci je vous laisse
répondre le ministre le préfet collègues
contenu je vous remercie vous dites
procréation sans sexe pour tous est ce
que c'est notre philosophie
non ce n'est pas notre philosophie nous
considérons que l'ouverture de la mp aux
couples de femmes avec tir d'honneur
ça correspond à un choix de vie qui me
semble-t-il doit être reconnu comme tel
et à la pluralité de modalités de
constitution des familles il y a dans
notre société aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
qu'un seul mode d'établissement des
familles et donc je pense que
l'ouverture de la mp à ces couples de
femmes
c'est la possibilité offerte de
constituer des modèles différents de
famille ça ne veut pas dire que nous
souhaitons favoriser la procréation sans
sexe je crois que ce qui importe pour
nous c'est de considérer et de respecter
ces différents modes d'établissement des
familles et à partir du moment où
l'enfant est là de sécuriser
juridiquement la filiation de cet enfant
est de sécuriser évidemment la filiation
par rapport aux deux maires à égalité
sur le deuxième point pas de filiation
paternelle
mon collègue drillien taquet complétera
sans doute est ce que je voudrais
ici dire c'est que là encore cela répond
à des pelures à une pluralité de modèles
familiaux et que d'autre part il y a un
certain nombre d'études qui ont été
effectués sur ces modèles de famille où
les enfants n'ont pas de pair au sens de
la filiation mais ça n'exclut d'une part
en aucun cas qu'ils aient des références
masculine dans leur entourage familial
très proche et d'autre part on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'ya eu il n'y aurait
pas d'incidence dans leur développement
psychologique il y a plusieurs études
qui ont été effectués en ce sens ensuite
vous m'interrogez sur la confusion
éventuel je prends votre dernière
question pour venir à la troisième sur
la confusion éventuelles qu'il y aurait
entre la reconnaissance conjointe que
nous établissons j'insiste sur le terme
ces reconnaissances conjointe alors que
l'article 316 ne parle pas de cela et je
voulais je le précisais dans mon propos
introductif sur les 316 nous sommes sur
une reconnaissance unilatérale
donc je ne crois pas qu'il puisse y
avoir de confusion juridique entre ces
deux types de reconnaissance la première
étant conjointe étant réalisée avant
même avant même que la grossesse
commence et l'autre étant réalisés
parfois après la naissance parfois juste
après la naissance parfois pendant la
grossesse donc on n'est pas du tout dans
la même temporalité pas dans les mêmes
effets enfin vous m'interrogez sur le
point de savoir pourquoi il n'y a pas
mention il n'est pas fait mention dans
le texte de la femme qui accouche
c'est un débat que
nous avons eu à l'assemblée nationale il
est évident évident que dans le cadre
d'une amp avec tiers donneur il faut par
définition que l'une des deux femmes
accouchent par définition sinon la
filiation ne peut pas être établie et
donc nous avons considéré que ce qui
était important puisque d'évidence
l'officier d'état civil aura devant lui
le certificat d'accouchement sinon il
peut pas établir la double filiation il
était important de sécuriser la
filiation pour l'autre mère mais encore
une fois cela ne signifie pas que d'une
part l'accouchement n'existe pas au
contraire je viens de le dire devant
vous et d'autre part je ne suis pas
fermé à une évolution éventuelle
d'écriture d'ailleurs nous avions à
l'assemblée nationale tenter cette
évolution d'écriture nous avons pensé
qu'il fallait laisser les choses évoluer
mais ce qui est important pour moi dans
cette filiation
c'est vraiment que les deux maires soit
à égalité et l'accouchement ne suffit
pas bien sûr il faut par définition
qu'il y ait une reconnaissance conjointe
auparavant qui permettra d'établir cette
filiation à égalité entre les deux mers
le dernier point que vous me posez c'est
pourquoi la femme non mariée parce que
nous sommes là dans le cadre d'une
l'établissement d'une filiation des
règles ne sont pas les mêmes suivant que
vous êtes pacsés non marié marié et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle le conseil
d'état nous a demandé juridiquement
d'utiliser le terme de femmes non
mariées je reconnais que c'est peut-être
curieux dans la lecture courante mais
celui qui emporte les conséquences
juridiques les plus exactes c'est
pourquoi nous avons repris ce terme là
voilà brièvement sur le président les
réponses que je souhaitais apporter ma
mère à bordeaux em jourda soit des
compléments d'information une petite
précision quel était donc la conséquence
d'utiliser le terme la femme célibataire
ou non en couple ou seul pardon
quelle était la conséquence du fait
d'utiliser le terme femme seule à la
place de femmes non mariées et bien
parce que il est important de ne pas
permettre à une femme mariée de
pratiquer seul une amp une femme mariée
si elle pratique seule une amp avec
tiers donneur
alors que le mari par exemple aurait pu
refuser une mpc l'a emporté des
conséquences juridiques importantes qui
ne sont pas les mêmes c'est une femme
seule qui pratique une amp une femme
seule qui pratique une mpl pratique une
amp seul monsieur tac et veut compléter
les réponses merci monsieur le président
oui en complément est dans la droite
ligne de ce qu'évoquait la garde des
sceaux sur la question de l'absence de
filiation paternelle
l'incidence que ça peut avoir sur sur
les enfants et sur les convaincus que
sur cet aspect là comme sur de nombreux
autres sur lequel nous reviendrons
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant a bien
évidemment été au coeur de nos
considérations
c'est ce sont effectivement près de 700
études qui ont eu cours au cours des 40
dernières années plus tôt à l'étranger
par construction sur les familles
monoparentales ou sur les sur les femmes
seules et ses études ont montré qu'il
n'y avait pas d'effet délétère pour
l'enfant pas de vulnérabilité
supplémentaires qui pourraient naître
d'avoir été élevé dans ces structures
famille la femme idéale là et n'ont plus
aucune incidence parce que c'est ce que
certains pourraient évoquer sur la
construction de la sexualité de ses
enfants
aucune incidence non plus pas
d'incidence effectivement d'être élevés
dans ces structures là parce que ce
n'est pas tant la structure familiale
qui compte mais bien la dynamique
familiale qui importait sa nombreux
travaux de pédopsychiatre nous montre
c'est la question de la relation est
question de la tension qui est portée
l'affection encore la question de la
sécurité dont d'ailleurs la conférence
de consensus qui avait été lancé sous le
ministère de votre collègue laurence
rossignol qui fait partie de cette
commission je crois qu'elle a été menée
par le professeur martin blachère et
montrer que la sécurité pour un enfant
et est le méta besoin sans lequel rien
d'autre ne pouvait être construit et qui
était au coeur au coeur de sa
construction de son développement est
effectivement l'altérité la garder sous
la très bien dit se trouve ailleurs et
d'ailleurs nous tous si on y réfléchit
un peu nous nous sommes tous construits
de liens d'attachement multiples
diverses qui vont bien au delà de notre
père ou de notre mère
si tenté que c'était la structure
familiale qui était qui était la nôtre
rappeler enfin pour conclure que
l'adoption pour les femmes soient les
possibles depuis 1996 et pour les femmes
en couple depuis 2013 donc ces questions
là ont d'ores et déjà aussi été évoqué
ce qui nous empêchera pas de les évoquer
à nouveau mais elle avait déjà fait
l'objet de deux discussions voilà au
final ce sont des millions de femmes
seules qui ont pu élever leurs enfants
par le passé des millions d'enfants qui
ont été élevés par des femmes seules il
faudra on y reviendra faire le distinguo
entre la monoparentalité subi et choisit
ce qu'il ya une vraie distinction
être parent c'est pas une histoire
gamètes ça c'est une histoire de désir
d'amour voilà et c'est ça qui est qui
est central dans la construction de
l'enfant merci mais merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre aurait
voulu vous avoir votre sentiment au
sujet de l'article 21 bis qui a été
ajoutée à l'assemblée nationale et qui
porte sur les enfants présentant une
variation du développement génitales cet
article vise à une meilleure prise en
charge en en faisant référence à la
nécessité d'une expertise par un des
centres de référence des maladies rares
du développement génitales et il vise
clairement à donner un peu de temps dans
certaines situations complexes par une
expertise pluridisciplinaire par la
sollicitation quand c'est possible de la
vie de l'enfant lui-même et donc on
comprend bien que healy a
potentiellement une répercussion sur les
questions liées à l'état civil
et c'est le sens de ma question puisque
la détermination du sexe pouvant être
différée comment voyez-vous cet
articulet l'articulation de cette prise
en charge
différer dans le temps prenant le temps
de la réflexion et du mûrissement de la
situation de l'enfant concerné
comment voyez vous cette articulation
avec l'inscription à l'état civil
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur je
ne suis pas sûr d'être en situation la
meilleure pour répondre précisément à
vos questions dans votre question de ma
collègue agnès buzyn ou peut-être
frédéric seront plus à même mieux à même
que moi de le faire
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que cette
prise en charge des enfants qui
présentent des variations du
développement génitales c'est un sujet
que nous avons abordé sous différents
angles
d'abord au sein du gouvernement entre
nous puisque c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous réfléchissions beaucoup et nous
avions juridiquement évoqué la
possibilité de repousser la déclaration
à l'état civil de quelques mois pour
permettre disons d'établir le sexe de
l'enfant
on avait envisagé de repousser de trois
mois
cette cet établissement de l'état civil
et puis plusieurs personnes des
associations nous ont dit que trois mois
c'était insuffisant que ça obliger à
faire des choix qui était trop précoce
certains défendant l'idée qu'il fallait
attendre l'adolescence pour que le choix
s'établissent etc
donc nous avons renoncé à cette mesure
concernant l'établissement de l'état
civil mais il a été introduit ce que
vous avez vu c'est à dire le fait que la
prise en charge d'un enfant relève d'
équipe pluridisciplinaire spécialisé
donc de centres de référence des
maladies rares du développement
génitales et ma collègue agnès buzyn a
beaucoup insisté sur ce sujet en disant
que c'était l'endroit où les familles
pouvaient trouver un appui un soutien
important et des conseils médicaux
solidement ancrée pour trouver la
solution la meilleure au problème et
donc avec vous l'avez vu une
concertation qui doit proposer des
pistes thérapeutiques possibles y
compris d'ailleurs l'abstention
thérapeutique qui est envisagée comme
l'une des possibilités voilà moi je peux
difficilement
aller au delà sans doute faudra-t-il que
vous posiez à nouveau cette question à
agnès buzyn sauf si vous souhaitez
apporter quelque chose de nouveau adrien
jeunes c'est sur l'aspect juridique
vague était la question de l'état civil
non mais pour conforter en tout cas ce
qu'il vient effectivement d'évoquer à
garder sous le dispositif qui a été
adoptée et de voir effectivement mieux
accompagner les parents on sait que
c'est des situations qui sont parfois
difficiles qui serait qui se résolvent
entre guillemets très très très tôt sans
que les parents puissent forcément
sereinement apprécié cela donc le
dispositif qui a été introduit par le
par les parlementaires et bien de celui
de créer une commission
pluridisciplinaire qui puisse
accompagner les parents dans ce dans ce
choix et ça sera par arrêté que la
composition de cette commission
pluridisciplinaire sera sera détaillé
voilée spécifique tel qu'il est sur
l'aspect accompagnement thérapeutique
parce que je vais juste pour reprendre
un peu ambitieux ministre
c'est ce dispositif n'a pas été adopté
par les parlementaires mais pour
l'instant pris par les députés
connaissant la position du rapporteur je
crois qu'il faut insister comme ça c'est
bien la question de la prise en charge
on l'a bien comprise dans l'arctique les
motivations l'article mais la question
il paraît difficile de d'aborder la
question de la prise en charge est
d'instituer ont prise en charge qui est
de qualité effectivement parce que je
partage les objectifs de cet article
mais sans que la question de l'état
civil soit résolu c'est tout de même une
difficulté première
si je peux me permettre d'acheter
quelque chose je suis sénateur nous
avons
d'une part simplifier les modifications
qui peuvent être apportées à l'état
civil
il ya des possibilités de rectification
de l'état civil qui se font de manière
relativement simple désormais donc on
peut déclarer l'enfant à l'état civil
mais ensuite on peut demander une
rectification une modification de
manière simple et d'autre part nous
sommes en train de travailler
alors peut-être pour nous évolue en ce
sens dans nos débats
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
deux possibilités qui sont envisageables
encore une fois le report de la mention
du sexe à l'état civil ce qui peut être
l'une des possibilités ou bien ce que je
vous disais la rectification qui est
peut-être facilitée j'avais donc passé
la parole aux collègues qui ont levé le
doigt le premier c'est monsieur amiel
oui à partir du moment où c'est le
concept d'égalité devant le fait d'avoir
un enfant qui préside finalement à
l'article comme l'était par l'article 4
et donc à partir du moment où on est
pour la pma pour tout homme pour
employer l'expression passe-partout et
j'en parle d'autant plus à l'aise ce
n'est pas mon cas comment se fait-il que
nous ne soyons pas allé jusqu'à la gpa
au terme de légalité parce qu'il me
semble quand même qu'au nom de la colle
est cohérent si on est pour l'égalité
devant le droit à l'enfant ce qui est
tout autre chose que le droit de
l'enfant comme le disait adrienne taquet
il semblerait logique il semblerait qu
est rare que d'ailleurs certains l'ont
dit très clairement je suis pas d'accord
mais c'est pas la question je me pose en
termes de cohérence qu'on ne soit pas
allé jusqu'au bout des choses
après on peut appeler ça bien sûr gpa
éthique on peut l'appeler de de
différentes façons de vincent a sabordé
par rapport au risque qui à mon avis est
important de marchandisation
mais sur le plan de la cohérence en
matière d'égalité permettez moi
d'insister je ne vois pas pourquoi on
n'est pas allé finalement jusqu'au bout
avec votre projet de réforme mais
ouverte aux couples de femmes c'est
comme
une réforme qui aura des conséquences en
propre aux logiques importante et quand
on pouvait affirmer qu'il n'aura pas
d'incidence psychologique pour pour les
enfants qui seraient privés de père même
si vous avancez un certain nombre
d'études et j'ai une deuxième question
qui n'était pas très original mais c'est
vrai que vous puissiez clarifier bien
votre position ce qui au nom d'un
principe d'égalité
vous avez donc ces pma ouverte aux
couples de femmes et même aux femmes
seules
comment pouvez vous être sûr qu au nom
de ce principe les couples d'hommes ne
revendique pas aussi un inévitablement
là j'ai bien donc quelle est votre
position sur la gpa merci je vous laisse
répondre merci monsieur le président la
dernière question rejoint la première
puisque la première question portait
également sur la gpa et monsieur le
sénateur je ne sais plus qui m'a posé la
question cela miel pardon voilà monsieur
ses intérêts mais elle pardonnez moi me
demander au fond pourquoi est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas allé jusqu'au bout et au
nom du principe d'égalité devant le
droit à l'enfant m'avez vous dit on
aurait pu aller plus loin et donc de ce
fait pourquoi nous ne restons pas la gpa
peut-être deux éléments si vous me le
permettez monsieur le sénateur c'est
également une manière de vous répondre
le premier élément c'est que et de
conseil d'état le dis clairement il n'y
a pas de droit à l'enfant
il n'y a pas de droit à l'enfant
l'enfant est évidemment inclus dans un
projet de constitution d'une famille
dans un projet
dans un projet parental mais il n'y a
pas de droit à l'enfant l'enfant n'est
pas du tout un vraiment on ne peut pas
parler de droit à l'enfant et sa le
conseil d'état la firme très très très
clairement par ailleurs le principe
d'égalité ne peut pas jouer de manière
absolue le principe d'égalité il joue
pour des personnes qui par rapport à
l'objectif c'est à dire à la procréation
sont dans la même situation
or un couple de femmes un couple
hétérosexuel
un couple d'hommes ils ne sont pas
juridiquement dans la même situation par
rapport à la question de la procréation
et donc vous ne pouvez pas appliqué à
l'un de ces couples les règles que vous
appliquez aux autres
là encore la jurisprudence est très
claire de ce point de vue là le constat
est extrêmement clair donc autrement dit
pour la gpa
on peut ni prétendre qu'il y a un droit
à l'enfant ni dire que le principe
d'égalité joue et il se trouve que dans
notre droit
nous avons clairement inscrit dans le
code civil l'interdiction de la
gestation pour autrui considérant
évidemment par rapport aux grands
principes sur lesquels nous font donc
n'autorisons pas la gpa donc on ne peut
pas déduire de la pma le fait que
juridiquement cela instaure une
évolution vers la gpa j'aborderai donc
là la question du titre iv vraiment
toutes nos excuses parce qu'on le fait
dans le désordre le plus total
en vous disant tout d'abord que nous
avons une première conviction qui est
très largement partagé je sais par par
l'ensemble des parlementaires et par
l'ensemble de notre société en réalité
qui est que ce que la science sait
rendre possible n'est pas nécessairement
aligné sur ce que notre société souhaite
et donc résoudre cette tension entre ce
que sait faire la recherche et les
aspirations de notre société c'est le
coeur même de notre droit de la
bioéthique et de ses lois de bioéthique
qui sont régulièrement révisées le sénat
vous le savez là aussi beaucoup mieux
que moi jouent un rôle considérable
depuis 1994 dans la construction de ce
droit et l'ensemble de la communauté de
la recherche
en tout cas c'est ce qu'elle doit à la
haute assemblée
s'agissant de l'instauration de régimes
d'autorisation en matière de recherche
sur les cellules souches embryonnaires
notamment l'encadrement de la recherche
est souvent un travail de funambule car
il ne faut évidemment pas sacrifier nos
valeurs fondamentales à une quête
éperdue et permanente du savoir mais il
ne faut pas non plus sacrifiée l'espoir
de développer la connaissance la
compréhension des thérapies innovantes
de guérir des maladies aujourd'hui
incurables
il ne faut pas sacrifier ses espoirs sur
des préjugés qui ne correspondent plus à
l'état des connaissances
donc ce projet de loi de révision de la
loi de bioéthique s'agissant de son
volet recherche propose en fait un cadre
juridique rénové avec à la fois sur
certains sujets sains des choses qui
vont être rendue plus facile pour la
recherche mais aussi parce que la
recherche a progressé de nouvelles
règles et de deux nouvelles prise en
compte de l'implication que peuvent
avoir les percées scientifiques en
matière de recherche sur l'embryon en
matière de cellules souches
embryonnaires ou encore en matière de
cellules souches induites en matière de
recherche sur l'embryon notamment ce
texte prévoit d'autoriser les chercheurs
à conduire des recherches permettant
l'édition du génome d'embryons qui ne
font plus l'objet d'un projet parental
et qui sont donc destinés à être
détruits puisqu'en fait je rappelle que
en aucun cas évidemment les
dans des embryons ne sont créé à des
fins de recherche ce sont toujours des
embryons qui sont conçus dans le cadre
d'un projet parental
et lorsque ce projet parental est
satisfait ou abandonner la demande est
formulée de savoir si les embryons
doivent être détruits ou si ils peuvent
être utilisés à des fins de recherche
et c'est uniquement dans le cas où ils
sont autorisés à être utilisés pour des
femmes recherchent que qu'ils sont de
fait utilise donc c'est ses recherches
sur l'édition du génome notamment on le
sait apporte des connaissances
essentielles pour comprendre le rôle des
différents gènes dans les mécanismes de
différenciation de nos cellules qui sont
évidemment à l'oeuvre au cours d'une
développement mais qui sont aussi à
l'heure dans beaucoup à l'oeuvre dans
beaucoup d'autres processus que ce soit
des processus physiologiques comme le
vieillissement ou des processus
pathologiques comme le cancer
parallèlement le projet de loi souhaite
introduire une limite de 14 jours à
l'observation des embryons in vitro de
façon à ce que ces embryons ne puisse
pas se développer au-delà d'un stade
particulier qu'on appelle le stade de
l'organe génèse nous avons souhaité donc
introduire cette limite de 14 jours
qu'il n'existait pas dans le texte
précédent et cette limite dans
n'existait pas dans le texte précédent
tout simplement parce qu'on ne savait
pas observé des embryons plus de
quelques jours
donc personne n'avait jugé utile de
fixer une limite d'observation
aujourd'hui on sait observer ces
embryons plus que quelques jours et donc
ça nous paraît important de fixer cette
limite donc c'est toujours dans cet
esprit a autorisé des choses et lorsque
les connaissances scientifiques nous
amène à en interdire d'autres êtres
capables de prendre de prendre ça en
compte
comme je les dis aimer je préfère
vraiment le répéter les interdits
fondateur de notre droit comme des
textes internationaux dont nous sommes
signataires sont évidemment tous
confirmés on ne crée pas d'embryons à
des fins de recherche
on ne modifie pas le patrimoine
génétique transmissible à la descendance
et on n'intègre pas de cellules animales
dans un embryon humain c'est trois
choses restent absolument interdite
et ceci a été réaffirmée très clairement
par le gouvernement en séance publique à
l'assemblée nationale
et finalement ce texte ne touche pas à
ses 3 interdit majeur ce texte a pour
vocation de protéger notre modèle en
respectant donc ce statut particulier de
l'embryon et en empêchant par là même
toute possibilité de clonage de
modification de patrimoine génétique
d'un embryon destiné à être réimplantés
mais ne nous prive pas d innovations
thérapeutiques qui peuvent être mises au
point si nous comprenons mieux les
mécanismes de développement de
différenciation cellulaire et de
développement normal ou pathologique
je devrais peut-être insisté sur la
question des chimères qui a suscité
beaucoup d'interrogations
lors de l'examen du projet de loi qui
vous est aujourd'hui soumis dans le
cadre actuel de la loi de bioéthique
l'introduction de matériel génétique
animale dans un embryon humain et très
clairement interdit puisque ceux ci est
dans le la partie de la loi qui concerne
l'embryon humain et donc il est très
clairement inquiétante indiqué qu'on ne
veut pas rajouter de cellules d'une
autre espèce dans un embryon humain mais
rien n'a été dit sur la réciproque c'est
à dire la possibilité d'utiliser des
cellules humaines dans un embryon animal
se trouve que cette possibilité
d'utiliser des cellules humaines dans
dans un embryon animal nous permet de
produire ce que l'on appelle des modèles
qui permettent de comprendre là encore
des pathologies humaines
de préparer des traitements c'est
vraiment de cela qu'il s'agit ni plus ni
moins et c'est pour ça que nous avons
souhaité clarifier les choses d'une part
réaffirmé l'interdiction de mettre des
cellules animales dans des embryons
humains et ensuite indiqué que m des
cellules humaines dans un embryon animal
était évidemment soumis au contrôle et à
la réglementation puisque il y avait
manipulation de cellules humaines
embryonnaires sur la question des
cellules souches embryonnaires et de
leur capacité à se transformer en
n'importe quel type de cellules du corps
humain qui est la définition la plus
simple que l'on peut donner de ces
cellules souches embryonnaires
elles sont évidemment à l'origine de
beaucoup d'espoirs en termes de thérapie
cellulaire ou en terme de ce qu'on
appelle la médecine régénérative à
l'horizon des recherches sur ces
cellules souches embryonnaires
il ya l'espoir de traiter des maladies
aussi diverses que la maladie de
parkinson des insuffisances cardiaques
le diabète et c'est donc vraiment un
très fort potentiel de thérapie
cellulaire et de médecine régénérative
actuellement dans la loi les cellules
souches embryonnaires sont soumises au
même régime que la recherche sur
l'embryon alors qu'aujourd'hui là encore
les progrès de la science font que
embryons et cellules souches
embryonnaires ne nous semble plus
relevée du même questionnement éthique
pourquoi cela parce que à l'époque de
l'écriture de la version actuelle de la
loi pour produire des cellules souches
embryonnaires il fallait détruire un
embryon pour mettre ces cellules souches
embryonnaires en culture aujourd'hui
nous maîtrisons des techniques qui nous
permettent en fait d'utiliser des
lignées de cellules souches qui ont été
dérivées d'embryons parfois il ya
plusieurs dizaines d'années est donc
utilisé des cellules souches
embryonnaires aujourd'hui ne signifie en
aucun cas avoir eu accès dans le
laboratoire en question à un embryon
donc ce que nous avons souhaité s'est
différencié
la recherche sur l'embryon de la
recherche sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires
sauf évidemment si celle-ci dérive
directement d'un embryon dans ce cas là
c'est la réglementation sur l'embryon
qui s'applique donc notre proposition
dans ce dans ce projet de loi c'est
d'alléger le régime de recherche sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires de les
laisser soumise à une autorisation
pardon de la laisse est soumise à une
déclaration et non plus à une
autorisation comme dans le cas de la
recherche sur l'embryon
nous avons dans ce contexte réfléchi à
la question des cellules souches
pluripotentes induites les cellules
souches pluripotentes induites sont des
cellules adultes que la science permet
de faire revenir vers un état qui
ressemble à celui des cellules souches
embryonnaires
à partir de ces cellules souches
induites
nous pouvons donc produire un certain
nombre de cellules de l'organisme mais
pas toutes les cellules comme c'est le
cas pour les cellules souches
embryonnaires
autrement dit finalement la question que
nous nous sommes posée c'est est ce que
à partir de ces cellules souches
pluripotentes induites
il peut y avoir des questions éthiques
qui se pose est notamment lorsque ces
cellules souches pluripotentes sont
induites en gamme est qu'ils peuvent à
ce moment-là repartir dans un cycle 2 de
questionnements éthiques
et donc ce que nous avons souhaité c'est
là encore m une partie des recherches
sur ces cellules souches pluripotentes
induites notamment salé qui peuvent être
utilisés pour produire du matériel
génétique les soumettre là aussi à un
régime d'autorisation
on entend parfois dire que on pourrait
remplacer les cellules souches
embryonnaires par les cellules souches
pluripotentes induites
c'est loin d'être une certitude
aujourd'hui et donc c'est pour ça que
c'est important de pouvoir garder des
recherches sur ces deux types de
cellules qui en fait en réalité son sont
différentes
nous avons donc ouvert dans ce titre iv
de nouvelles voies tracées de nouvelles
limites réaffirmé un certain nombre de
lignes rouges de façon à ce que nous
puissions garantir la réalité du
contrôle des dispositions qui seront
indiqués dans la loi et que nous
puissions aussi soutenir
évidemment la qualité de notre recherche
scientifique qui est une recherche qui
est en réalité en nous avons cette
chance libre et responsable dans notre
pays
voilà j'ai envie de dire que la
recherche et la connaissance rendent
notre avenir possible mais que c'est
bien le rôle du législateur que de
définir le chemin emprunté l'horizon
souhaité et la couleur la couleur de cet
avenir si je puis dire voilà très
brièvement et en quelques mots les
principaux points saillants du titre iv
de ce projet de loi est bien sûr je
serai ravi de répondre à vos questions
merci même lis je le laisse continuer
monsieur taquet
avec avec plaisir non surprise toujours
agréable je m'apprêtais surtout elle
fait un propos assez générale qui n'a
plus vraiment de sens vu l'ordre ou le
désordre dans lequel nous avons procédé
donc je réponds favorablement à votre
invitation vous faisant l'économie de
ces propos généraux donc été introductif
mais qui n'aurait plus beaucoup de sens
maintenant mais peut-être revenir un
petit peu sur les sujets qui ont d'ores
et déjà été un peu évoquée avec la garde
des sceaux qui concerne notamment
l'ouverture la procréation médicalement
assistée à toutes les femmes et aux
femmes seules me permettant peut-être de
réinsisté sur certains propos tenus
précédemment et de revenir aussi non pas
tant sous l'angle juridique mais plus du
point de vue du développement de
l'enfant sur la question de l'accès aux
origines qui est un point important et
qui occupera je pense non nos
discussions pour rebondir un petit peu
sur les questions les propos du sénateur
amiel notamment ceux d'hier ma collègue
me contredira si elle n'est pas d'accord
là dessus mais que le loi de bioéthique
n'est pas une
ce n'est pas une voie d'égalité et ce
n'est pas la recherche de l'égalité
notamment qui nous a guidés une botte
bioéthique s'est passé au prisme de
l'éthique un certain nombre d'évolutions
des techniques médicales et sait mettre
en adéquation évolution des techniques
avec les principes éthiques que nous
souhaitons que nous souhaitons mener est
donc parti partant de là
il n'y a jamais eu et il n'y aura pas
effectivement comme l'a dit la garde des
sceaux de droit à l'enfant ce n'était
pas le cas pour les couples
hétérosexuels par le passé ça ne sera
pas le coup le cap pardon pour les les
couples homosexuels ou pour les pour les
femmes seules dans l'avenir à l'avenir
par lé droit à l'enfant ça serait
insinué que l'enfant serait dorénavant à
la merci de toutes les fantaisies qui
serait le simple produit d'un caprice
ça serait dénigrer le projet parental et
ne pas reconnaître ce que sont les
poires court dames paix pour tous les
couples qui sont des parcours souvent
long compliqué difficile qui nécessite
d'être accompagné quelle que soit la
structure familiale et d'ailleurs nous
avons les députés ont voulu renforcer
l'accompagnement justement de ces de ce
processus de ce cheminement
par ailleurs je l' ai déjà dit les
familles monoparentales homoparentales
existent déjà c'est un fait il sera
aussi là peut-être un peu hypocrite de
ne pas le voir de persister à ne pas le
reconnaître je les dis c'est souvent ces
familles sont souvent issus de projets
très long avec des enfants qui sont
ardemment désiré était parents ne me
semble me donnera qui sont des parents
tout simplement ni plus ni moins si la
famille est un point de repère les
d'abord et avant tout une histoire et un
parcours et qu'il importe à chacun de
connaître de comprendre et sur la
question des origines connaître ses
origines
pour les enfants c'est trouver la
réponse à une question qui est légitime
qui est peut-être la plus légitime de
toutes les questions d'ailleurs qu'un
être humain peut se poser qui est doué
ce que je viens et notre conviction
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
faut sortir la dissimulation qu'il faut
rompre avec cette logique du secret dont
on a pu penser longtemps qu'elle
protégeait mais dont en réalité on sait
aujourd'hui qu'elle abîme
vous avez vu vous avez fait des
auditions
vous avez rencontré des enfants et la mp
vous allez rencontrer peut-être arthur
de kamal velzen qui un peu en pointe sur
toutes ces questions là et on sait que
ces enfants ne sont pas à la recherche
d'un père est pas le sujet soit la
recherche d'un récit d'une histoire
dont ils nous disent qu'elle est
importante à la construction de ce
qu'ils sont donc oui nous pensons même
si ce n'est pas toujours simple
la famille est désormais un lieu où l'on
peut on doit même se dire les choses et
dans le cadre de la mp avec don famille
hétérosexuelle ont le choix sera laissé
aux parents de le dire et on
l'accompagnement qui est fait sur ce
cheminement que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure on leur dira qu'il est important
pour l'intérêt de l'enfant pour sa
construction future de lui dire quelles
sont ses origines
une fois encore je le répète ici nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir permettre
à l'enfant d'accéder à sa majorité
s'ils le souhaitent s'ils le souhaitent
à des informations relatives au donneur
c'est lui permette non pas de traquer un
individu non pas d'ouvrir un conflit et
bien au contraire de se construire comme
individu de se pacifier avec son
histoire et donc avec avec lui même
c'est ce que nous disent les enfants
soyons clair un donneur n'est pas un
parent ce n'est pas sa vocation
ce n'est pas ce que nous organisons ce
n'est pas le sens de son geste
d'ailleurs mais il est une pièce de
l'identité de l'enfant que nous qu'on ne
peut pas dérobé à cet enfant enfin
donner accès aux origines dans cette loi
c'est aussi sortir le don du secret non
pas de l'anonymat des choses soient très
claires nous ne revenons pas ce principe
fondamental qu'est l'anonymat du nom
mais c'est bien sortir le don du secret
pour le reconnaître dans ce qui l'a
profondément humain ce qui est
profondément altruiste de ce qu'il est
profondément solidaire et ce faisant
nous n'affirmons qu'une seule chose la
force des institutions qui ont vocation
encadré et protéger chacun avec un seul
choix celui de la responsabilité
individuelle et collective et cette
force d'institutions cet esprit de
responsabilité ce qui guidera aussi ce
qui a guidé et ce qui guidera dans nos
discussions dans nos débats les choix
que nous vous proposerons de faire dans
d'autres domaines qui sont tout aussi
complexe variés que
la question d'autoconservation de
gamètes pour les femmes comme pour les
hommes
ou encore je pense à la question de
l'amélioration de la qualité de la
sécurité des pratiques pour les dons
d'organes ou les missions des
conseillers en génétique ou encore
développement dans le respect évidemment
de nos valeurs éthiques de la médecine
génomique dans le cadre du soin ou de la
recherche
frédéric vidal a commencé à évoquer
voilà et puis vous redire peut-être un
petit tout petit peu plus de la place où
je suis mais partagent évidemment par
les quatre ministres qui qui seront avec
vous et l'ensemble du gouvernement que
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant a guidé
nos réflexions
je pense notamment à la mp post mortem
ou là aussi le principe d'égalité aurait
pu sera peut-être dans nos débats mise
en avant mais nous avons décidé de faire
primer l'intérêt super de l'enfant car
moi je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
de naître dans le deuil pour le
développement futur de l'enfant et c'est
ce qui nous a conduits à effectivement à
le a lieu à l'interdire voilà donc
autant de sujets qui susciteront
évidemment des questions dès maintenant
et en séance et des interrogations des
débats riches et passionnants nous
sommes tous convaincus
merci journée merci à vous je vais donc
commencer par donner la parole à vos
rapporteurs en commençant par madame
humbert merci monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre merci monsieur
le ministre vous vos propos je vais
aborder de points donc qui concerne le
titre carte 4 dont je vais m'adresser à
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche et d'innovation vous
avez rappelé madame la ministre à
volonté du gouvernement que ce projet de
loi ne nous prive pas d évolution
scientifique
vous maintenez je parlais de la ruche la
recherche notamment de la recherche sur
l'embryon
vous maintenez l'autorisation par l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
des recherches menées sur l'embryon dans
le cadre de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation alors que la cour des
comptes critique est une procédure
lourdes et complexes qui décourage
parfois et souvent les chercheurs
d'autant que ces recherches ne constitue
pas le coeur de métier le coeur de l'
expertise de la rsm etc en pratique elle
se tourne vers l' agence de biomédecine
pour avoir un avis est que souvent
j'allais dire presque de façon constante
l'avis de l'asn est conforme à celui de
l' agence de la biomédecine
donc pourquoi ne pas confier tout
simplement cette mission à l' agence de
la biomédecine qui dispose déjà de
l'expertisé nécessaire sur l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et sur la
recherche sur l'embryon
quitte à lui faire appliquer les
dispositions spécifiques aux recherches
cliniques ne pourriez vous pas justement
renforcer les moyens de l'agencé de
biomédecine pour examiner ces projets de
recherche clinique et je note par
ailleurs que vous souhaitiez dans le
projet de loi supprime et un agence de
biomédecine sa mission en matière de
nano biotechnologies au motif qu'elle ne
disposait pas d expertise dans ce
domaine
mais n'est ce pas je vais dire de votre
responsabilité de lui donner les moyens
humains et matériels de cette expertise
si je voulais être un peu taquine je
dirais que si nous devions supprimés aux
agences toutes les missions que l'état
ne finance pas il ne restera peut-être
plus grand chose j'ai dit que j'allais
taquine madame la ministre
un deuxième point est là qui revient qui
rejoint le point des chimères vous
l'avez dit rien n'a été dit sur la
possibilité d'utiliser des cellules
humaines dans un embryon animal vous
donner cette possibilité dans ce projet
de loi et vous dites que c'est soumis au
contrôle c'est-à-dire qu'elles
contrôlent
vous supprimez ainsi l'interdiction
générale de création d'embryons
chimérique étrangers nique et vous ne me
tenez qu'une interdiction et vous ne
l'avez bien expliqué d'insérer dans un
embryon humain des cellules animales
vous autorisez donc la jonction de
cellules souches humaines à des embryons
animaux en vue de leur transfert la
femelle ne pensez vous pas qu'il y a là
un vrai risque de franchissement de la
barrière des espèces
merci bien joué se répondre aux
rapporteurs jeu passera un rapporteur
par un monte enfin le groupe des
sénateurs
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
le président je vais peut-être commencer
par par la dernière question parce que
j'ai bien senti que j'étais pas à
complètement clair actuellement il n'y a
pas une interdiction générale de créer
des embryons chimérique
actuellement il ya interdiction de créer
des embryons chimérique dans une partie
du texte qui fait référence aux embryons
humains
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de l'interdiction à l'insertion de
cellules humaines
sauf si ce sont les cellules
embryonnaires dans des embryons animaux
et donc en fait que nous faisons c'est
que nous remettons les choses à leur
place si je puis dire là où on est dans
la partie du texte qui parle des
embryons humains
nous précisons que il est interdit de
mettre des cellules animales dans des
embryons humains et nous remettons dans
le texte de bioéthique le fait que pour
mettre des cellules embryonnaires
humaines dans des embryons animaux il
faut procéder à à la demande de
déclaration d'usagé des cellules souches
embryonnaires humaines et donc on a bien
ce contrôle qui à mon sens est beaucoup
plus efficace en étant rappelé que dans
le flou qui existait auparavant où il
était fait référence à des embryons
chimérique mais seulement dans la partie
de la loi
qui faisait référence aux embryons
humains voilà donc on précise simplement
aux rats ont réécrit ce qui était déjà
écrit dans la loi mais en sécurisant et
en enlevant le flou juridique
voilà je ne sais pas si je suis clair
mais honnêtement il y a dans les
laboratoires et c'est déjà très
largement pratiqué sans qu'on n'ait
jamais observé de franchissement de
barrière d'espèce création de modèles de
pathologies humaines où il s'agit de
regarder comment se développe quelques
cellules humaines dans un contexte
d'embryons d'animal et voilà je sont des
choses qui existent si je puis dire et
simplement ce que nous avons voulu faire
dans cette nouvelle version on aurait pu
laisser strictement ce qui existait
auparavant mais il nous semblait qu'il y
avait une forme de flou juridique
puisque en fait ça ne s'appliquait que
aux embryons humains
puisqu'on était dans un article à une
partie de la loi qui concernait les
embryons humains
donc on a bouffé simplement on réécrit
les choses de manière moins floue
puisque c'est c'est vraiment notre
attention a été attirée sur ce fait sur
le fait que finalement rien dans la loi
de bioéthique ne l'indiqué quoi que ce
soit sur la question de chineurs
d'embryons chimérique fait dans des
embryons animaux et donc on le on leur
met de manière très explicite
parce que ça n'est pas interdit de fait
et que de fait ça se fait depuis très
longtemps dans les laboratoires mais
simplement au pr précise les conditions
dans lesquelles s'est fait actuellement
dans les laboratoires et dans lesquels
ne souhaitons que ça puisse continuer
continuer
à être fait sur la question de la
nacelle on entre dans le cadre de la
recherche interventionnelle sur la
personne humaine
lorsque l'on touche à des embryons qui
ont vocation à être réimplantés et donc
ça ne relève pas de l'agencé de
biomédecine
mais ça relève bien de quelque chose qui
touche à la personne humaine et donc
voilà cesser ces règles là qui sont qui
sont actuellement actuellement utilisé
les questionnements de la rsm ne sont
pas les mêmes questionnements que ceux
de la bm et c'est pour ça qu'il nous
paraît important que la question de la
recherche sur des embryons qui ont
vocation à être réimplantés soit bien
continue bien à être soumise et rentre
dans le cadre de ses recherches
interventionnelles sur sur la personne
humaine
il s'agit dans ce cas là je le rappelle
en aucun cas de modifier l'embryon - il
s'agit dans ce cas là de rajouter par
exemple au moment de la fécondation in
vitro ou sur un embryons obtenus après
fécondation in vitro un certain nombre
de molécules qui vont avoir pour objet
de faciliter la réimplantation de
l'embryon par exemple chez la mère est
donc en fait on affecte la mer si je
puis dire en enrobant l'embryon d'un
certain nombre de molécules qui vont
faciliter l'implantation de l'embryon
voilà l'exemple de choses qui sont qui
ceux qui se sont regroupés dans cette
recherche sur l'embryon à des fins de mp
puisque je le rappelle il est totalement
interdit de modifier génétiquement un
embryon avant réimplantation donc ça
relève sa relève en fait de de l'air et
ph
sur la question des délais ça je suis
tout à fait consciente que on a un sujet
avec avec ces délais voilà c'est un
effectivement un engagement de la part
de la bm de tenir les délais et pour
cela sa demande et de n'avoir finalement
à traiter que des questions sur
lesquelles elles s'estiment totalement
légitime et sur les questions que vous
évoquez elle est elle même obligé
d'aller chercher de l' expertise
ailleurs et ce qui crée aussi une forme
d'embouteillages
voilà merci bien
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez dans vos propos
évoqué cette question qui nous taraude
de la tension entre ce que sait faire la
recherche et les limites que nous
voulons fixer et donc je reviens sur un
certain nombre de questions qui
concernent précisément l'article 17
parce que vous avez aussi évoqué la
question de l' équilibre il nous
interroge sur cette question de l'
équilibre et est ce que c'est quand même
pas une forme de bouleversements j'ai
bien entendu vos vos réponses mais
malgré tout cet article supprime et
c'est écrit l'interdiction générale de
création d'embryons chimérique
alors bien évidemment c'est non destinés
à des fins de gestation mais se pose
quand même la question de savoir
jusqu'où peut-on aller dans le
franchissement de la barrière des
espèces et comment l' agence de
biomédecine appréciera s'il s'agit de
chimères comment va-t-on apprécié cette
cette limite 7 proportions acceptables
et la deuxième question est ce qu'on va
pas à l'occasion de cet article 17
alors qu'on parle souvent de l'éthique à
la française un peu plus loin que ce qui
se passe dans nombre de pays c'est à
dire que est ce qu'on n'est pas dans une
situation quelque peu paradoxale autre
question vous abordez la suppression de
l'interdiction de création d'embryons
transgénique est ce qu'il s'agit
d'expérimenter le l'édition au génomique
crise perd 4,9 et notamment de modifier
le génome d'embryons destinait transfert
à des fins de gestation et est-ce qu'on
n'ouvre pas la porte à une remise en
cause de l'interdiction de modifier les
caractéristiques génétiques
transmissibles voilà je vais jusqu'au
bout de des craintes qui peuvent être
les nôtres et et les miennes parce que
je j'ai le sentiment que cet article 17
à quelque chose de bouleversant et qu'il
vient au coeur de ce qu'on appelle les
ti-cats à la française
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors en
fait absolument pas vraiment je voudrais
vous rassurer sur les deux points et
vous dire que c'est absolument pas
l'idée effectivement on a supprimé la
création d'embryons chimérique est
interdite mais une fois de plus vu
l'endroit où ceux ci étaient placés dans
le texte cela ne concernait que des
cellules animales dans un embryon humain
donc nous avons réécrit effectivement la
modification d'un embryon humain par
adjonction de cellules provenant
d'autres espèces est interdite ce qui
revient à réécrire exactement la même
chose vue là où cette phrase était placé
auparavant dans la loi de bioéthique
l'adjonction de cellules d'origine
humaine dans des embryons d'origine
animale une fois de plus ça se pratique
dans tous les laboratoires du monde ça
se pratique y compris dans les
laboratoires français ça n'était
absolument pas interdit par la loi de
bioéthique donc on ne franchit rien du
tout et on continue à faire ce qui se
fait déjà dans les laboratoires la
différence fondamentale c'est qu'on
précise ici qu'on ne peut pas du tout
modifié un embryon humain et que on
continue à dire que lorsque l'on modifie
un embryon animal par adjonction de
cellules embryonnaires humaines
ce qui compte c'est qu'on soit obligé de
demander l'autorisation pourrait fermer
comme comme c'est le cas actuellement
en fait on se contente de préciser les
choses puisque dans la loi de bioéthique
il n'est jamais question d'embryons
animaux il est juste question d'embryons
humains donc ce que l'on fait là c'est
simplement qu'on lève un flou juridique
sur lequel notre attention a été attirée
puisque tel que sse été formulée la
création d'embryons chimérique est
interdite
là où s'était placé dans le texte ça
faisait qu'il n'y avait finalement
aucune référence à l' or ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on mettait des cellules humaines
dans un embryon animal
donc voilà c'est juste on lève ce doute
là et une fois de plus ça se pratique
très largement dans tous les
laboratoires du monde et je sais qu'on
entend on entend souvent parler jusqu'à
y compris de la possibilité d'avoir des
organes pour les greffes produite à
partir d'animaux et c'est là on en est
encore très loin enfin voila quand il
enfin et donc je vous laisse imaginer
comme on n'en est qu'aux monnaie encore
plus loin de la question de la barrière
d'espèce
donc voilà c'est simplement par souci de
lever un flou juridique qui faisaient
que on ne parlait pas des embryons
animaux sur la question de l'édition du
génome ou bien sûr il s'agit d'utiliser
crise par cast 9 par exemple parce que
c'est ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui mais
de façon générale d'éditer le génome
mais vraiment la convention d'oviedo est
ce que l'on aura réaffirme dans ce
projet de loi de bioéthique
c'est qu'il est formellement interdit de
réimplanter un embryon qui a été
génétiquement modifiés ça fait partie
des débats que nous avons eus à
l'assemblée nationale puisque un certain
nombre de personnes disaient pourquoi
est-ce que si nous sommes capables
d'enlever maintenant de manière très
précise
un gène défectueux qui serait dominant
et donc de laisser la copie du gène non
défectueuse s'exprimer et donc de
potentiellement guérir une maladie
pourquoi est ce qu'on s'en priverait et
notre réponse a été de lierre parce que
nous ne souhaitons pas réimplanter
d'embryons modifiées génétiquement par
par l'édition du génome par contre nous
souhaitons bien autorisé l'édition du
génome dans des embryons pour comprendre
quel va être l'impact de ces
modifications du jeune homme en
observant les embryons en culture
pendant 14 jours mais pas au delà de 14
jours et là aussi
c'est une question qui a été longuement
discutée justement pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne va pas plus loin que 14 jours
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne va pas au moins
jusqu'à 21 jours etc
nous avons souhaité proposer cette
limite de 14 jours qui est la limite de
ce qu'on appelle lé organogenèse
c'est-à-dire pour faire simple le moment
à partir du quinzième jour on est
capable de différencier de faire la
différence dans un embryon entre les
cellules qui vont donner qui seront à
l'origine du système nerveux et les
autres et donc nous avons souhaité fixer
14 jours parce qu'à 14 jours nous ne
sommes pas capables de faire cette
différence est donc ce qu'on appelle le
stade début d'organogénèse il y avait
des demandes d'aller plus loin il lui
demande de s'arrêter plus tôt
voilà nous proposons cette date de 14
jours parce que c'est celle qui nous
paraît raisonnable
merci madame humbert merci monsieur le
président une question supplémentaire
dans ses recherches qui portent sur un
embryon animal auquel on a ajouté des
cellules humaines
pouvez vous nous dire jusqu'à quel stade
de développement ces embryons sont
étudiées alors c'est extrêmement
variable
ça dépend complètement du type de
cellules qui sont qui sont mises dans
l'embryon parfois c'est une observation
de quelques jours qu'il suffit
aujourd'hui c'est certain par exemple
quand on étudie les questions liées aux
caractéristiques des cellules
immunitaires dans les souris les
souriceaux nes mais voilà la seule chose
qu'on a modifié dans ce cas là c'est le
fait que ces sourisseau porte un certain
nombre d'anti gènes humains et donc on
est capable d'étudier la réponse à
certains médicaments sur ces modèles
une fois plus c'est quelque chose qui se
fait de manière extrêmement courante
et on ne voit pas vraiment de raison
tout d'un coup de faire un bond en
arrière parce que ça fait plus de plus
de 30 ans puisque je peux vous en parler
en toute connaissance de cause que
oratoire merci bien monsieur juillet moi
j'aurais voulu vous poser une question
que complémentaires sur les embryons sur
leur durée de conservation j'aurais
voulu savoir
vous proposez un délai de cinq ans
comment avez-vous estimé ce délai est ce
qui se fonde sur la le stock nécessaire
pour ne pas induire de rupture dans les
activités de recherche sur l'embryon
comment quelles méthodes avez vous
utilisé pour déterminer cette cette
durée de 2 5 ans
je n'ai pas le souvenir monsieur le
rapporteur qu'on a modifié la durée de
conservation
on a gardé ce qui se pratique
actuellement c'est à dire une durée de
conservation de cinq ans voilà donc il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de raison
particulière à cela on n'est pas en
pénurie
si je puis dire d'embryons dont les
parents acceptent qu'ils soient confiées
à la recherche plutôt que détruits donc
on n'a pas modifié
on n'a pas modifié cette durée de
conservation c'est une question qui peut
être posée par certains scientifiques et
que j'entends mais voilà on sait pas
très bien répondre à cette question là
parce que en fait là lorsque l'on génère
des embryons dans le cas d'un projet
parental
le stade auquel on les congèle pour les
garder au cas où la première fécondation
in vitro par exemple n'aurait pas
fonctionné et très différents
aujourd'hui de ce que l'on faisait
encore il ya dix ou douze ans et donc
certains disent nous on aurait besoin
d'observer les choses qui se passent
juste après la fécondation au stade une
cellule alors qu'aujourd'hui on conserve
les embryons en général un stade un peu
plus tardif parce que ça augmente les
chances de succès ensuite de la
réimplantation voilà on a décidé qu'on
gardait cinq ans parce que parce que de
toutes les façons il ya quasiment plus
de stock d'embryons à une cellule donc
merci monsieur amie à elle maintenant
oui par rapport au concept même de loi
de bioéthique
monsieur le ministre vous disiez que les
lois de bioéthique sont là pour
accompagner les progrès qu'il peut y
avoir en matière médicale la matière
biologique soit technologique
thérapeutique et cetera d'une façon
éthique
or la pma ce n'est pas lié à une
question de progrès ont certes il ya des
progrès en matière de recherche sur
l'implantation de l'embryon
mais c'est pas le sujet qui est là d'où
ma question est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
été préférable alors évidemment la
question arrive bien tard de dissocier
le débat de bioéthique proprement dit
qu'elle tels que ce qu'a pu à bord ont
pu aborder madame vidal concernant les
recherches sur les cellules souches
embryonnaires ou sur l'embryon et le et
le débat sur la pma parce que on a
l'impression c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui mais enfin kassav sera
probablement le cas dans les débats et
l'accompagnement médiatique qu'il y aura
que le débat sur la pma confisqué un
petit peu tout le reste concernant la
bioéthique proprement dite je lis
proprement dit parce que je pèse
persiste à penser je suis pas le seul
que la question de la pma ne relève pas
de la bioéthique mais d'une simple
question d'éthique ou de morale sociétal
donc la première loi de bioéthique a été
provoquée par la pme au-delà de ça vous
avez raison les lois de bioéthique là où
je vous suis où je complète en tout cas
fille sur les changes que nous avons
initié c'est que gestion de m bioethics
est appréhendé au prisme des évolutions
au prisme pardon de nos principes
éthiques l'évolution des différentes
techniques en prenant en considération
aussi les évolutions de la société
cet égard on peut justifier en tout cas
comprendre que la pma fasse partie
intégrante de ces bioéthique mais pour
vous rassurer s'il en était besoin ou en
tout cas partagé un peu
l'expérience qui a été la nôtre à
l'assemblée nationale par la crainte que
vous exposiez que cela phagocyte un peu
bon nombre d'autres sujets dont on sent
bien au travers de nos premiers échanges
et dont on l'avait senti à l'assemblée
nationale et et chacun le sait ici sont
en réalité probablement bien plus
impliquant vertigineux pour certains
d'entre eux que la question de la
science de la mp et à l'assemblée
nationale
effectivement la mp a occupé de la place
mais progressivement et parmi les
parlementaires et parmi la presse qui
suivait les débats les autres sujets ont
occupé toute la place qu'il méritait et
je trouve que d'ailleurs l'audition que
nous avons cet après-midi le démontre
aussi puisque nous avons notamment
beaucoup parlé de questions liées à la
génétique et puisqu'ils sont
effectivement à ses fondamentaux dans le
texte que nous que nous examinons la
question qui est plutôt en fait une une
constatation c'est que effectivement
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit que à
l'assemblée nationale comme dans ce
projet de loi vous n'avez pas été sur la
pma post mortem
nous avons su ici en audition un certain
nombre de professeurs qui sont en lien
avec des couples qui ont des difficultés
justement pour avoir des enfants il se
trouve que parfois ils sont parfois très
peu de fois en fait
confronté aux difficultés d'un couple
dont l'un des deux décède enfin plutôt
l'homme d'ailleurs et donc on leur dit à
partir de ce moment là qu'ils ne peuvent
pas enfin qu'elle ne peut pas utiliser
soit l'embryon soit soit les gamètes de
son époux et donc soit il faut les
détruire soit elle peut les donner à un
autre couple et donc les professeurs que
nous avons rencontrés nous ont dit que
c'était face à quelque chose de
quasiment inhumain à dire et sans doute
à vivre pour justement cette ces femmes
qui restent justement avec
7 cette idée que justement elles ne
pourront pas poursuivre le projet qu'ils
avaient imaginé à 2 et moi j'ai bien
entendu combien vous disiez que
justement un projet de pma c'était aussi
une manière dynamique de voilà on était
dans une dynamique et là tout d'un coup
là effectivement la dynamique seront
puisque l'un des deux décède
mais pour autant il existait un projet
parental qui étaient construits et en
fait aujourd'hui avec l'ouverture à la
pma pour les femmes célibataires et bien
on peut se dire que cette femme qui
devient d'un coup peuvent elle pourra
faire elle pourra finalement concevoir
un enfant sains avec un autre donneur
que l'époux qu'elle a auparavant et mais
enfin je trouve que c'est complètement
inhumain et je pense que on pourrait
envisager la pma post mortem avec un
certain nombre de d'éléments cadres
notamment par rapport au temps 1 entre
justement ce projet et le moment du
veuvage
parce qu'on peut pas s'empêcher aussi de
faire le parallèle avec des couples qui
conçoivent un enfant de manière tout à
fait naturelle et dont l'un des scènes
en tout cas le mari décède et donc la
femme expliquera aussi cette histoire
familiale à cet enfant à naître
donc voilà c'est plutôt pour vous dire
que moi je trouve que une loi de
bioéthique certes n'est pas pour régler
un problème humain ou pas humain mais en
l'occurrence moi j'entends d'une part la
voie des experts ceux qui sont auprès de
ces familles et qui doivent leur dire
d'aidé comment ces choses là et puis le
fait que finalement l'ouverture de la
pma aux femmes célibataires et bien les
mettre dans une situation qui est
incompréhensible pour tout être humain
pour vous répondre
même de nos sur sur la pma post mortem
ça a été
source de beaucoup beaucoup de
discussions parce que effectivement y
compris dans l'élaboration du projet de
loi
les questions sont un petit peu abyssal
pourquoi est ce que finalement dans le
projet de loi qui est qui vous est
proposé à après passage à l'assemblée
la pma post mortem n'est pas autorisée
d'abord parce que il ya un vrai sujet
lié au temps du deuil est ce que
immédiatement après le deuil on ne se
dit pas oui je sais mon rêve le plus
cher que de faire naître un enfant et
puis après un an deux ans finalement le
temps passant la vie reprenant ses
droits
est-ce qu'on est toujours dans avec la
même envie au moment où potentiellement
on se retrouve enceinte de l'enfant en
question et donc ça c'est un première
une première question comment on gère le
temps de deuil
alors on peut se dire on ne peut pas en
autorise la peña post mortem mais
seulement après une période
comment est-ce qu'on estime la durée
d'un deuil
c'est encore une autre question à
laquelle on avait eu un peu de mal à
répondre
le projet parental porté par été portée
par le couple qu'est-ce qui se passe
enfin la maintenance est plus un couple
c'est une une des deux personnes du
couple enfin en l'occurrence la femme
qui continuent à porter seul un projet
parental conçu à 2 bon alors ça voudrait
dire que potentiellement il faudrait
aussi demander
[Musique]
si l'autre parent serait d'accord au cas
où il décède pour qu'un enfant naisse
après sa mort enfin ça nous paraît là
encore un peu vertigineux
quelles peuvent être les pressions
potentielles des familles au moment du
deuil notamment de la famille du défunt
sur la possibilité ou pas de devoir un
enfant d'être après le décès de l'être
cher
comment on gère la question des
successions on gèle toutes les
successions en imaginant que l'autre
personne a déjà des enfants comment on
prend ça en compte
bon tout ceci nous a amenés à continuer
a interdit enfin à interdire la pma la
pma post mortem dans le texte
sachant que pour terminer en réalité le
nombre de cas réels c'est-à-dire où il
ya des demandes formulées auprès de la
justice
c'est un nombre de cas extrêmement
faible et donc on s'est dit que c'était
peut-être pas la peine d'ouvrir la
possibilité de généraliser une pma post
mortem
alors que finalement au regard de la
lourdeur du processus parce qu'il faut
enfin on prononce rapidement pma mais
derrière c'est un processus qui est
quand même lourd techniquement aussi qui
présentent des risques qui évidemment ne
fonctionne pas à tous les coups enfin
voilà il faut se remettre dans une
logique de temps long comme un an
la pma pour tout répond à la
transformation de nos sociétés 7pm à
n'entraînera pas l'ouverture de la gpa
la gestation pour autrui
voilà quelques-unes des idées défendues
par le gouvernement
le projet de loi bioéthique va être
examiné par les sénateurs dans les
semaines qui viennent on suivra ça bien
évidemment sur public sénat en attendant
je vous souhaite une excellente journée
sur notre antenne
[Musique]